Robert I'm really glad that I'm sitting
with you today not only to talk about
Tribeca but also to settle this great
debate that's happening over on Twitter
I'm not sure if you're aware there is
this poll that has the internet divided
over 40 million people have checked it
out they are completely divided 50 50.
who is hotter a young Al Pacino or a
young Robertson oh boy so give it to me
straight Who's hotter I don't know
you're Al
what am I going to say it's 50 50.
that's the way oh come on Bobby it's you
man it's you but speaking of hell I
don't know what's in the water these
days but your friend Al is welcoming a
child have you had the opportunity to
congratulate him not yet no I just heard
about this morning did you so what do
you make of the news good for him is
there something in the water who knows
and I gotta say congratulations to you
Robert of course you welcomed little Gia
who my gosh she's got a head full of
hair she's a cutie yeah how does it feel
having a newborn great yeah she's just
great is it putting a little spring in
your step
well it helps
she's just an adorable Young
little innocent thing it's just amazing
did you think you'd be back on diaper
duty
well I don't do the heavy lifting I I
will admit but I tried I'm trying to do
more not that I haven't done it in years
years ago but anyway I'll try I'm trying
my best wonderful well congratulations
to you and both Tiffany as well of
course we saw y'all make your red carpet
debut at can with killers of the flower
Moon how was the experience for you and
Tiffany hitting that carpet good great
yeah great did she enjoy it yeah
well it's craziness it's uh but it's
organized crazy how is it I mean because
can just seems like a whole nother Beast
being out there on that carpet it's a
lot I'm sort of used to it I've been
through it before but it's great
move said the great white father
there are many
you received a nine minute standing
ovation for the film yeah wow what does
that feel like having someone having a
crowd stand for you for nine minutes
clapping we were very happy
um listen I'd rather be doing standing
there for nine minutes for with a
standing ovation as opposed to being
booed for nine minutes I'd say so yeah
that definitely feels a lot better
because that that audience the audiences
can and known for that booing certain
movies and stuff like that really yeah I
mean I would it wasn't going to happen
with Marty's film of course but still
they do do it they're very clear about
how they feel about things which is
great I can't believe it's already that
time for Tribeca unbelievable year went
fast it surely did and here we are upon
the 22nd annual event for a Tribeca
Festival opening night is going to be
kiss the future it's a documentary
produced by Ben Affleck Matt Damon Bono
last year y'all had JLo she kicked
things off so this year you've got her
husband so what makes these these folks
some of the best people to kick off the
festival they tell great stories uh they
tell great stories and they tell unusual
stories this one about the musicians
that saved the heart and soul of
Sarajevo during The Siege and with so
many more great documentaries uh uh
documentary about the Ukrainian
Comedians and a lot of green music docs
French Montana uh Cindy Lauper Indigo
Girls it's just going to be a fun
Festival got a special event going on
for Bronx Tale Of course that was your
directorial debut Jane this was your one
of your first producing gigs so when you
think back to this movie what was the
most memorable moment for you Robert
well there are a lot of things I thought
you know the actors were terrific who I
used the kids were great I was very
proud of the film I'm looking forward to
segue into this I'm looking forward to
seeing it at the Beacon Theater theater
I love and with a big audience hopefully
and just get the reaction because it's
been a while since I saw it and it's a
new print it's all everything great so
cool might we ever see you direct again
I don't know it takes a lot of work and
I and I like to it's just that's great
it's just Define something you want to
spend that much time on
um I love directing and who knows I I
who knows I might still might do one
more incredible well speaking of
directing we are seeing record number
female directors at this year's Tribeca
you're in one of the most diverse
festivals out there so why is that so
important to you Jane and what do you
attribute really to being the reason for
so many female selections this year I
don't know I personally as a woman you
want to see more women and give more
women the support that they deserve and
you know you want to see you want
different points of view as uh you know
the world has so many points of view
it's not always through the lens of the
um you know old white guy
um or young white guy
he has supported so many women
um and myself very much included and you
know allowed me to have enough rope to
go out and ensure that we can support a
diverse community of filmmakers lgbtq
all types of filmmakers and our programs
at Tribeca whether it's our ATT untold
stories and giving out a million dollars
to underserved filmmakers and diverse
storytelling uh or the work we do with
PNG and Queen Latifah or the work we're
doing with Chanel on through her lens we
are committed to telling uh telling
those stories but you know most
importantly to supporting
the men and women behind the camera and
not just the ones not just directors but
everybody else behind the camera because
that's how the system will eventually
change
[Music]